alright so I saw transformers 4 last
night on my 38th birthday yeah I went to
transformers
age of extinction i've seen the first three
course everyone seen on the first one
was by in the tag along with horrific
third one is pretty awful but with these
things that come from your childhood
units endless hope or at least I do this
and let's hope
that they're gonna be better somehow
it's gonna get you back to that place
when you're a kid in you because
unadulteratedly love something
and that the first hour but movie I
could not believe it they were doing it
it had a backstory related to the the
dyno bites and dinosaur that it was cool
and something is happening in about
science fiction E
and look cool and I was like old cow
Michael Bay is proving me wrong he could
finally do it
and then for the next six hours it
devolved into a horrible painstakingly
painful
awful explosion fares that we've come to
believe about these things
it's a workable point that I wanted to
make and then I'm gonna wrap this thing
up in a nice little bow and make an
offer to Hollywood
at so for some reason Optimus Prime who
is if you watch the original
transformers the cartoon
he was a great guy in a leader who
believe in the right thing Michael Bay
has turned him into a bipolar psycho
path we as a lil
blood last and want to just kill
everybody that's just not how it should
be
against should not be like that that's
not happen is prime but
forgetting that forgetting dislike
picked the child up I read the product
placement in this movie
with on fucking believable a truck a Bud
Light
just hit balls over Mark Marky Mark
whatever they may start drinking
by like they'd beat Saudi like it's just
painful it was people in the whole thing
with the commercial per-child a
cuz that's really where they're trying
to push his movies made on the ladder in
China
and they just want to give China are
crap China usually gives us
their crap so I guess we were flipping
it on China so maybe Michael his
religion is I
the whole the Arab it wasn't for kids
because it's so violent they were
cursing in Justin's is a mess
but also not for adults because if you
have a functioning brain
is not for you either so do one thing
that's poor kid and poor adult
I would recommend that you see the 1986
Transformers movie
the original generation one animation
and it's amazing and it's brilliant and
its artistic Orson Welles by the boys
and
Unicron and it's just ban freakin tastic
and all the things that are wrong with
these craptastic disasters
they're alright in that movie and it
made me think that Michael Bay
so Michael be the director these things
he can't remember all that because there
are people that ride
those people should be in jail but
Michael Bay he directs these things and
they're just these
endless it's just this cacophony
explosion and then if it makes sense in
you start thinking it make sense and
there's an added that doesn't make sense
in a character that doesn't make sense
to keep your hands down anyone saying
million this is America Michael Bay is
America
we'd love to blow shit up we don't know
what we're doing were mixed messages
where over budget and were just selling
crap endlessly so Michael Bay is like
the perfect
metaphor for america and I sorted admire
him for that and I understand he cried
destroy me
it very easily to so here the offer that
I wanna meet EU Hollywood
II as someone that loves the
Transformers are loved loved what they
were
at one time I will direct the next
Transformers movie I think its time
Michael Bay's have enough for this now
you guys
I will direct the next Transformers
movie I would do it for minimum wage
and I'll do it for I have no idea to
budge on the thing was I think was $300
million bucks %uh do it for three
million bucks I will figure out a way
I would reckon extra towards we will be
better than all the Transformers movies
and and then I will also start a class
action
lawsuit against michael bey and will
have been deported Bieber
aka thanks